heute zeige ich euch das rezept für
nutella cheesecake muffins wir brauchen
400 gramm doppel ram frischkäse ein
teelöffel vanille extrakt 100 gramm
zucker 2 eier 30 gramm mehl 200 gramm
schmand oder creme fraiche je nachdem
was sie gerade daran habt außerdem
brauchen wir noch ein hotel für den kern
der cheesecake und für den boden
brauchen wir noch unbekannt oder wie in
meinem fall runde butterkekse ihr müsst
nur darauf achten dass die vom
durchmesser her in eurem afx in form
passen
für dieses rezept brauchen keine
küchenmaschine wir fahren jetzt erstmal
den frischkäse mit dem vanille extrakt
und danach gehen wir die eier hinzu
darin geben wir dann unseren zucker dann
geben wir unseren schmand oder creme
fraiche hinein je nachdem was ihr da
habt und es macht wirklich keinen
unterschied welches der beiden sorten
ihr benutzt als allerletztes liebe ich
noch das meer hinein damit alles
klümpchen frei ist
jetzt nehmen wir uns unser muffin blech
und lägen auf dem boden die kekse auf
die kekse kommt jetzt in die mitte
jeweils einen teelöffel nutella
und darauf verteilen wir jetzt unsere
käsemasse
die kommen jetzt in den vorgeheizten
backofen bei 150 grad ober unterhitze
für 20 minuten
anschließend müsst ihr sie noch
auskühlen lassen und am besten im
kühlschrank lagern
ich wünsche euch ganz viel spaß beim
nachmachen und wenn ihr noch mehr solche
rezepte sehen wollt dann lasst mir gerne
in abo da